he's going to get beat up by a singer a
musician a seashell collector an amateur
disney boy
i'm all of these who have you ever beat
up you ain't beat up nobody
you ain't beat up nobody
you
oh he's bigger than me oh he's a
heavyweight and all this and all that
that's that's cut because we coming to
cruise away
thank you
thank you so don't don't yeah
no that's not you cannot do that that's
out that's out so we will you know
you'll be 215 on the night of the fight
you don't know how much i'll be 195. you
don't know how much i'm away on the
night of the fight
yes sir
okay guys face out please
bone's down the middle
jake back here for five all right let's
get amanda in we know he's gonna come
out southpaw so i mean fighting a
southpaw for the first time but other
than that nothing really changes you
know i fight professional boxers in the
gym sparm all the time two three times a
week for the past three years guy's way
better than him steve cunningham
three-time world champion guys like that
caliber so nothing really changes we're
prepared for this you know i i take hard
challenges
and challenge myself more and more with
each fight increase the level of
opposition and give the fans what they
want people say fight over a boxer here
we go this guy is bigger than me he has
more experience there's no reason that i
should win this but i'm proving to the
world and proving to the kids out there
that if you set your mind to something
and you truly believe in yourself and
you're dedicated and you're mentally
low-key have to be insane well he has a
name you know for me it's hard to find a
perfect opponent because they have to
have a big name and they have to be
a
good fighter they have to be a
professional boxer i wanted to check
that off the list and so he just fit the
whole entire description and i know what
i'm capable of if i'm knocking everyone
out at cruiserweight then why can't i
knock out someone at heavyweight you
know this is surreal like the fact that
this is all happening is a dream come
true you know the the 12 year old
version of myself would be giving me a
high five then you'd be so proud of what
i've done and what i've accomplished and
this was a dream come true i wrote it
down on my bucket list when i was 18
years old to sell out madison square
garden i didn't know what it was going
to be for or why
but here we are seven years later
selling out the most iconic venue in the
world it's pretty remarkable i want to
thank a lot for this opportunity and
just to be here on this on this platform
just to be at this stage this is such a
huge opportunity i never once ever once
even
second guessed or
or sec even doubted the outcome of this
fight is i did no negotiation through
the uh through the internet and i'm not
going to
but uh whatever they sent me they sent
me and they said look this is take it or
leave it either you take it or you leave
it or ain't no fight and i took it i'm
gonna be the lowest paid opponent but
i'm the biggest i'm i'm the biggest i'm
the one that's giving you any
credibility none of your other opponents
gave you any credibility so why
shouldn't i get more than him
but like i said i'm not here to
negotiate through the media i'm not here
to do none of that i'm i'm here to end
this facade that he's calling a career
so we're gonna see
we will and
and
we're gonna see on august 6th when jake
paul falls we're definitely gonna see
that
you